[оплески]
[музика]
це допомагає жити
треба йти до кінця треба брати до
останнього
українська збірна на іграх нескорених
тут кожен учасник має свою унікальну
історію та всіх об'єднує одне власним
прикладом вони доводять що жодна бойова
травма не може зламати силу духу Не
дивлячись на втрату кінцівки чи травми
українська команда не втратила жахода
Перемоги
подивитися на гру українських учасників
в об'єднаній команді з регбі на візках
прийшов і принц Гаррі саме він заснував
ігри нескорених у 2014 році втім на
коментарі у принца часу не було
[музика]
Тана церемонії відкриття змагань Гаррі у
своїй промові виразив повагу українській
збірній
Я хочу відзначити команду України із
зокрема одну конкретну людину тайру
[оплески]
а от під час матчу українських гравців
появу поважного гостя навіть не помітили
Я не знав що нас дивиться Ну я дуже
радий що мені це сказали бо тому що він
в принципі я так розумію що він вболівав
за нас також Чи прийшов подивитися як ми
граємо з іншими Тобто Ну то нема того що
за когось конкретно прийшов Я сподіваюсь
кому сподобалось але жодні Перемоги у
жодних іграх каже Павло не важливі поки
немає перемоги найбільшої
Незалежності перестану гинути наші люди
і наші військові тоді буде справжнє
відчуття перемоги А так це тимчасова
радість задоволення і я сподіваюсь що
все-таки вона допоможе багатьом іншим
хлопцям які з нами грали
адаптуватися реалізуватись і краще типу
Ну відкинути негативне думки Ну і весь
негатив війни в себе хоча би на певний
час
це допомагає жити
дім для поваги девіз ігор нескорених
цього року це спортивні змагання для
ветеранів та військовослужбовців які
зазнали травм у Німеччині змагання
відбуваються вперше
українську команду представляють 25
спортсменів військовослужбовців у 10
видах спорту регбі на візках волейбол
сидячи баскетбол далі йдуть
настільний теніс стрільба з лука
індивідуальні види пауерліфтинг
веслування легка атлетика плавання це
місце де всі один одного поважають
де цінності є не боротьба за результат
за медалі за нагороди А за повернення до
нормального абсолютно нормального життя
тут немає людей які нерівні між собою
всі рівні всі рівних умовах всі один
одного поважають
всі один одного підтримують допомагають
один одному всіх цих людей об'єднує
спорт і допомагає їм повернутися до і
відчувати себе так як вони відчували до
отриманих трав на початку в німецьких
Дюссельдорф на ігри мало їхати лише 24
учасники та Дода місце спеціально
зарезервували для парамедикинь Юлії
паєвської відомої як Тайра яку на
церемонії відкриття згадував принц Гаррі
під час минулорічних змагань доброволець
перебувала у російському полоні і не
змогла взяти участь
[оплески]
в Донецькому сезоні підвалах ну тобто
це те що в списку завдань
галочками стояла що зроблена А тепер
буде зроблено
Ну тому що я обіцяю
через проблеми з хребтом Тайра тимчасово
пересіла у візок але своєї участі у
змаганнях не скасувала
[оплески]
скільки є сили А я Надія чи ні Треба все
одно виходить Як сьогодні вийшла
дізналася вже не буде добре результату
але якщо я не з'явлюсь
на змагання це ніби я злякалась Я не
боюсь саме адаптація ключова мета ігор
нескорених через війну Росії проти
України дуже багато жінок та чоловіків
отримують поранення і про те як їм
адаптовуватися і реабілітовуватися в
суспільстві потрібно думати вже зараз
створювати умови для реабілітації а
спорт - це невід'ємна складова
реабілітація як такої Тому що тут
особливо перебуваючи на змаганнях такого
рівня
люди бачать яка підтримка їх всіх
об'єднує одна ціль одна мета і це
надихає насправді
це надихає люди повертаються І зовсім
іншого рівня багато людей приїжджає з
різного роду травму є видимі і невидимі
там візи Балан візи були плавно є
посттравматичний синдроми які візуально
ми можемо навіть не бачити але ми навіть
не уявляємо що в людей в голові
відбувається люди можуть бути замкнуті
люди можуть просто важко переносити не
знаю велику кількість людей навколо них
їм потрібен час на адаптацію
Звичайно що важко адаптуватися але в
першу чергу треба прийняти себе
змиритися з тим і прийняти себе І Далі
буде набагато краще жити і суспільство
тебе любить І ти полюбиш щось їсти
на цьогорічних іграх 600 учасників із 22
країн попри тут змагання всі підтримують
один одного
[музика]
за неймовірно Я абсолютно вражений тому
що всі ми знаємо що відбувається в
Україні але коли члени збірної України
приїжджають сюди і представляють країну
родини та людей вдома це дуже емоційно
коли ви думаєте про це і треба
стримувати сльози усвідомлюючи все те що
через що вони проходять але вони все
одно прийшли сюди сім'ями мають сили
посміхатися і підбадьорювати інше
підтримку Україні й український збірній
на церемонії відкриття висловив і
міністр оборони Німеччини Борис
пісторіус
Ми ніколи не повинні припиняти підтримку
України незалежно від того скільки часу
це триватиме
крім ветеранів в українській команді
багато діючих військових які потім
планують вертатися на передову як от
капітан української збірної Олександр
Маковей або макоша як його лагідно
називають побратими так капітан збірної
виборює для команди з золото
максимум Хочеться зробити для країни
заявити світу про нас що в нас йде війна
нас гинуть хлопці такі як я які
позитивні які
цінують життя які хочуть жити в вільній
Україні і саме це донести світу щоб нам
наші партнери вони нам допомагають але
цього трошечки мало потрібно більше
потрібно літаки потрібні ракети
далекобійні потрібно закрити небо бо
тому що дуже важко воювати на передку
коли в тилу по твоїх будівлях по твоїх
рідних близьких прилітають ракети і ти
нічого не можеш з цим зробити саме
родина головне джерело мотивації для
Олександра як в бою так і в реабілітації
дружина це в мене взагалі Мій особистий
Янгол охоронець
Настя Моя донька - Це мій мотиватор
зараз завдяки дії я повернувся в спорт і
почав займатися спортом свою перемогу
капітан присвячує родині крім доньки і
дружини на змаганнях за військового
вболіває й однорічний синочок
[музика]
[сміх]
це взагалі це дитина яку я чекав дев'ять
років
Мені Бог дав сина наследника якраз
спадкоємця
який буде носити мої медалі
поки одні учасники української збірної
змагаються інші приходять їх
підтримувати Так Олександр Бутько
позивний терен після власного змагання у
жимі лежачи прийшов вболівати за друзів
[оплески]
у минулому бариста а з початком
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії
доброволець Олександр під час боїв у
Харківській області отримав важке
поранення і втратив обидві ноги Та це не
зупинило військового він написав книгу
виступає в театрі А тепер і показує
спортивні успіхи але для самого
Олександра справжній натхнення ті хто на
передовій ті кого грузує наш народ це і
є дійсно ті Герої які ведуть боротьбу і
до цих пір і я в якійсь мірі навіть
заздрюємо тому що
чесно кажучи замість цього всього я
поміняв зараз на не скажу що на окопа
але точно активні бойові дії бо хотілося
бути разом із ними скажемо так а для тих
хто зараз в такій ситуації після
поранення наприклад скляного хто
хочеться сказати нехай подивляться всі
можливості які можуть очікувати їх і не
варто похлюпуватись
тільки потрібно працювати над собою і
ось це все будь ласка доступне для
кожного для кожного буквально ветерана
для кожного пораненого військового тому
тільки вперед і кожен капітан своєї долі
[музика]
[оплески]